dans une crise sanitaire il ya bien sûr
l'état mais il n'ya pas que l'état il y
à la nation il y a les collectivités
territoriales les entreprises et
heureusement depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire on a vu à côté de l'état
souvent d'intelligence avec l'état de
très nombreuses autres entités publiques
ou privées venir s'associer à l'effort
collectif venir s'engager dans l'effort
collectif
je parlais tout à l'heure du fonds de
solidarité
le fonds de solidarité au fond qu'est-ce
que c'est un réceptacle financier qui a
pour objectif d'accompagner ceux dé
celle des entreprises les plus petites
qui se trouvent confrontés à une
interruption complète de leurs activités
parcellaire de leur activité et donc à
une difficulté qui met en cause leur
existence même l'état abondera ce fonds
il a créé il verse le premier étage
laitages automatique c'est la dg fip qui
le fait à cela des entreprises les
assureurs notamment à hauteur de 200
millions sont venus participer à ce
dispositif ils l'ont fait volontairement
après que nous ayons discuter avec eux
et je les remercie car c'est très utile
d'autres entreprises parfois
discrètement sans l'annoncer mais parce
qu'elle considérait qu'il fallait
participer à cet effort ont également
abondé le fonds de solidarité et les
régions ont accepté de verser 250
millions d'euros et d'instruire avec
l'état le deuxième étage du fonds qui
doit permettre d'accompagner un peu plus
encore les entreprises qui se trouvent
dans une situation particulière ou plus
difficile en fonction notamment d'une
appréciation régionale qui doit être
pouvoir qui doit être observé et est
mise en oeuvre voilà un exemple il y en
a beaucoup d'autres de collaboration
intelligente entre différentes entités
et notamment les collectivités
territoriales et l'état
mais il y en a mille autres les communes
ont très souvent remarquablement joué le
jeu de l'accompagnement des enfants des
soignants aux côtés de l'éducation
nationale dans certaines communes
complétant le dispositif ou le rendant
plus efficace dans d'autres
inventant des activités ou mettent en
oeuvre des activités périscolaires qui
pouvaient là encore être incroyablement
précieuse pour celles et ceux des
soignants qui avait besoin de faire
garder leurs enfants pour continuer à
être tout à leur tâche et et notamment à
l'hôpital
cette collaboration nous entendons la
chérir la préserver la développer c'est
la raison pour laquelle lorsque je
reçois les responsables politiques je le
fais avec les présidents des grandes
associations d'élus de façon à ce que
chacune des strates importante des
collectivités territoriales soit informé
et dans toute la mesure du possible
associés s'agissant des personnes les
plus fragiles accueillis dans des
structures collectives nous avons c'est
là que se joue si j'ose dire la deuxième
bataille
la première bataille et hospitalière je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure en réponse au
président patriat la deuxième bataille
est celle qui se livre dans les ehpad et
dont les structures qui accueillent
notamment des personnes en situation de
handicap pour la gagner il faut
mobiliser des moyens il faut faire en
sorte de pouvoir tester
il faut faire en sorte de pouvoir
protéger il faut mettre en place une
logistique qui est très particulière qui
lire il ya plus de sept mille
établissements sur l'ensemble du
territoire national qui relève de cette
logique le ministre des solidarités de
la santé a indiqué que sa priorité
c'était de développer les tests
notamment les tests virologiques dans
les ehpad dans les structures
collectives dont nous parlons pour
pouvoir le faire dans de bonnes
conditions
il faut évidemment pouvoir s'appuyer sur
les laboratoires départementaux vous les
avez vous même évoqué nous avons et ça
n'était pas si simple
je sais que certains se sont émus du
temps qu'il a fallu pour lever les
limites
la vérité c'est que ça n'était pas si
simple parce que les limites elles ont
été posées par des normes
ce n'est pas le gouvernement actuel qui
les ai inventées ces normes et elles
n'ont pas été inventés pour ennuyer le
monde
elles l'ont été parce qu'elle
garantissait un niveau de sécurité ou
bon voilà ça arrive et c'est bien je ne
critique pas le mais pour l'élever
le croyez moi c'est parfois un effort
bref je passe sur le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est possible et c'est tant mieux
nous allons donc pouvoir nous appuyer
sur ces structures de la même façon que
nous allons nous appuyer
parent travaille en bonne intelligence
menée par le ministre et par
l'association des départements de france
sur les structures départementales pour
collecter les tests et ensuite procéder
à leur analyse
c'est donc là aussi un travail en bonne
intelligence qui se construit il se
construit dans des circonstances uniques
véritablement dans notre histoire
j'allais dire récente même assez ancien
mais il est en train de se construire et
il se passe bien il doit se passer de
mieux en mieux
quel que soit le niveau de collectivité
nous devons gagner cette bataille et
nous ne la gagneront pas seule personne
ne la gagnera seul il faut donc faire en
sorte que cette intelligence des
territoires cette coordination des
bonnes volontés et des compétences
puissent effectuer dans les meilleures
conditions je sais que ça et là il y a
des frottements
je sais que ça et là il ya des
différences d'approché
ça n'est pas anormal et au fond ça ne
nous surprend pas l'important c'est que
chacun y mette du sien et qu'on dépasse
ses difficultés pour obtenir le résultat
recherché
merci la parole est maintenant